and now let's take a look and a listen
to this year's nominee for achievement
in sound mixing arrival bernard area
pistol and cloud line packs are rich
Kevin O'Connell nd right Robert McKenzie
and Peter Graves lala land
Andy Nelson Eiling Lee and Steve a moral
world worn a Star Wars story David
Parker Christopher's Caravaggio and
Stuart Wilson 13 hours the secret
soldiers of Benghazi
Gary Somers Jeffrey J haboos and Mac
release and the Oscar goes to max our
ridge
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Peter grace the first win in 21st
nomination for Kevin O'Connell this is
the second Oscar nomination and first
win for Robert McKenzie
and Andy right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh guys
thank you so much I can't even tell you
what this means to me
it means so much to me my boy scooper in
case you're up in the audience tonight
watching me my wife Heather's over there
this means so much to me I can't even
tell you Mel Gibson thank you so much
for taking us on this journey with you
Phil mechanic thank you for making this
possible
Rob Andy and Peter you guys are amazing
thank you so much I'd like to thank Tom
McCarthy and Dan Sharpe and all the fine
folks at Sony Pictures in Culver City
all the folks down his sound firm in
Sydney and a special thank you tonight -
my mother Skippy O'Connell who 39 years
ago got me a job in sound and when I
asked her mom how can I ever thank you
she looked at me and she said you know
I'll tell you how you can thank me you
can work hard you can work really hard
and then someday you go win yourself an
Oscar you can stand up there on that
stage you can thank me in front of the
whole world
mom I know you're looking down on me
tonight so thank you thank you all so
much I really appreciated